Film Courage: Harvey, you have seen so many
worlds.
You’ve seen the music world growing up with
your Dad, you’ve seen the basketball world,
advertising world, and now here in Los Angeles,
which is a totally different ball game in
many senses (no pun intended by the way).
At the risk of sounding too cliché with this,
can we talk about the dark times [in someone’s
career journey] and how you can come out of
them?
Because you’ve seen a lot, whether it is
from your own life or from other people.
How do you maintain a balance, because [Los
Angeles] is a very, very up and down town?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: It is a very up and down
business, up and down town.
You can get caught up in a lot here, specifically
in Los Angeles, about the approval of other
people.
I think our whole industry is built on the
approval of other people because you don’t
get paid if other people don’t like what
you do.
You are literally exposing yourself everyday
hoping other people like what you do and ultimately
hoping people they like you.
That’s dangerous to a person’s psyche,
to their personality.
It is almost better that we lived somewhere
else and didn’t have to deal with that.
But it’s just the reality of art, right?
It’s subjective.
And you’re not going to be successful if
people do not give you their approval and
say “I want to buy that record or that painting
or that sculpture or that film, whatever.”
So that’s the dangerous part.
That is when it gets dark is when you don’t
have enough success to support your…your…not
ego…but just not enough support to feel
good about yourself and you start doubting
your art or your passion or “is this what
I’m supposed to be doing, maybe I shouldn’t
be doing it?”
A funny thing is, that is a part of Buster
Moon (from the movie SING).
There’s a part in the movie where he talks
about that and that’s so real and so true.
It pertains to anybody who has ever moved
to LA to try to make music or try to be an
actress.
It can test your will, it can test your dedication.
A lot of people give up and they don’t make
it.
I don’t have the answer on how to push through
it other than believe in yourself and continue
to try and improve.
If anybody told me that they didn't like what
I did, I took it personally and I would go
back to work.
I would sit in my studio at the time which
was in a bedroom and I would just bang on
my keyboard and make another track.
And then do another one….and “Nope, don’t
like it”….
do another one…get better…get better.
I would really take a competitive approach
to it.
I was an athlete and to me it was like “I
have to beat the next person.”
So rather than start doubting myself or questioning
myself, I took people at their word.
It’s probably not good enough, let me get
better.
And I think that served me well and I still
try to do that.
When I’m doing a project, in the back of
my mind, there are people I’m thinking about
that I want to do better than and other people
who I want to hear this and I want them to
be mad because I did such a good job and other
people I want them to be proud that I did
such a good job.
So that is definitely a constant motivation
for me.
Film Courage: You can even see in SING that
some of them [the characters] have a few chips
other shoulders and that this is not really
a bad thing.
We always hear that [having a chip on one’s
shoulder] is a negative thing but it could
actually be good to have it because it’s
a driving force and if you don’t you’ll
get pummeled?
Harvey Mason, Jr: I don’t know.
Different people have different ways of coping
and dealing with it.
Some people make music or make art just for
themselves and they’re happy with that,
forget what everybody else says and I’m
just doing this because I love it.
This is one way of doing it.
I just chose to be very competitive and I
have kids.
I want my kids to be proud.
I want to leave a legacy after I’m done.
I want people to think I did good work.
I want to be able to lay down at the end and
say “Yeah.
I’m happy with what I did.
I’m happy with what I’ve left behind.”
I think art is a really important part of
our culture and our society and if I can create
anything that lasts beyond my life, I think
that will be great.
Not to get too philosophical but some of that
is my motivation, it’s not just about sitting
in a vacuum and making music that pleases
me.
I’m trying to do things that might affect
other people in a positive way.
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: What motivates you,
money, achievement, personal growth, recognition
or the work itself?